foreign
Thomas is with us in Greenville South
Carolina Hey Thomas welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey hey thanks for having me certainly
how can I help
so I work at a small manufacturing
company we got about 45 employees total
I've got a team of seven and
um I love some insight on how to help my
team see just a bigger picture of we're
all in the company trying to get a
single goal not our department versus
their Department
um and want to pitch in when we've got a
slow period let's go help another
department instead of having the you
know not my job syndrome I'm not going
over there wow what is the uh singular
Vision can you describe it how you would
tell those seven folks if I was sitting
there watching you talk about it
in a nutshell it's uh ship units ship
Breakers
um that's that's what we're trying to do
is we're we're a startup we've had about
three years going and and we're still
trying to just get in a rhythm of we
need to get product out the door that's
quality that's on time that meets
customer spec and that's our goal how
many times has this happened this
question you described where couple or
is it the whole team of seven that are
griping about pitching in and helping
another team
fairly unified I've got one guy who's
pretty consistently uh just quietly like
all right I'm gonna go over here and do
what I can but uh most everybody is very
comfortable with um
this is my job and they're doing a great
job with their job
um just not wanting to step outside of
that real house right but I mean is the
one guy or all seven don't want to help
the other team when it's slow and we
need to pitch in is it all seven or just
the one guy
no no one guy's doing a great job of
helping the other six oh the other six
yeah okay I'm staying in my world well
welcome to leadership
um what you got to figure out is what's
driving that bad attitude this is an
attitude
um it happens here at Ramsey Solutions
all the time where we all say hey we're
going to jump in and help and and and
it's it's about the big picture Mission
if this helps them it helps Ramsay if it
helps Ramsey it helps me it's it's we're
a part of a much bigger picture and and
so when someone's not bought into that
it is an attitude and you have to figure
out where is the attitude coming from is
it selfishness or is it that they don't
feel valued they don't feel like they're
bought into the big picture and I think
that's where you got to start Dave to
dive into that a little bit do you have
control over hiring and firing them
uh yeah
so you could hire new people into the
position
I could yeah okay all right because
you're probably gonna fire at least one
because you got somebody behind the
scenes that's running an undercurrent on
you
and setting the tone faster that they're
they're shoveling the poop in faster and
you shovel it out
and you don't know who that is yet
because right now you got a blanket six
you got one good guy six bad ones all
six of them aren't bad five of them are
followers one of them's the dog and he's
probably gonna get fired when you figure
out who he is
yeah probably the only way you're gonna
get this cleaned up
because this is a disease that's
contagious
it didn't just land in there randomly it
has spread
this attitude and so by the way winning
is also Contagious by the way
enthusiastic response to the outcome of
the whole organization is is contagious
too cold it's culture You're Building
inside the organization and so the way
we talk about around here is we often
say we
this is what we do we as a team guys we
as a team when there's a need over there
we're going to enthusiastically help if
you want to be a we
you're going to enthusiastically help
because that's what we do you may not
want to be a we you may opt out and if
you don't that you just let me know and
we'll work that out I'll help you get
your severance package together but we
are going to do this and because when we
help the whole place the whole place
makes more money and when the whole
place makes more money we all have
opportunity to be promoted we all have
opportunity to make more money because
the place is making more money when the
place is barely struggling to get this
ad gum product out the door because
we're standing over here with our
fingers in our ear then we are harming
ourselves because we're shaking up the
stability of the whole place
you know this money that gets paid in
payroll doesn't come from freaking Santa
Claus it comes from the customers saying
you did a good job profit is the
Applause your customers give you and so
when we need to get something done
around here it is for in our own
personal selfish best interest to make
this place run as good as it can run
because that gives us the most upside we
get nothing but downside by sitting on
our butts so we are going to be fired up
and wired up and we are going to take
the hill we're going to push the ball
over the line and score the freaking
touchdown that's what we are going to do
now it's up to you whether you want to
be a we or not I can't make you be a we
and Thomas A lot of times when I'm doing
a leadership conference people will ask
me uh how I motivate people I don't
motivate people I hire motivated people
and I fire demotivated people
and when I get enough motivated people
in the room the whole room will freaking
explode with electricity and I can't
make that happen but I can make the
environment happen because you cannot
win the Kentucky Derby with a donkey
yep you know who the dog is
you know who the problem child is
not not offhand because like I said
they're all they're they're great at
their job yeah when you take each one of
them off for coffee to the side and you
have this we discussion
watch your body language and watch the
eyes yeah okay I'll tell you the next
question
do I hear a sigh yeah I'll tell you
another technique I'm being lectured
again oh no this will be the last one
because you ain't gonna be here yeah so
Thomas there's another way to do this
too I agree you need to do the
one-on-one but I'll tell you the
quickest way to figure it out is put
them all in the room together all seven
guys and say hey when we've had to jump
in before I've noticed that we don't
have the best attitude and I want to
know your all thoughts what are your
stressors why do you what do you see
this just ask some open-ended questions
about what you see and get their
feelings and watch who they look at but
I don't think I don't think your snake
will say a thing
they'll look at the snake though watch
they'll look at them yeah they'll give a
shot eye yeah it might happen yeah good
I'm just saying that's one option but
Dave can I throw another scenario out
here real quick to Thomas sure this is
also a part of leadership it's why we do
it we do it on trade leadership and I
the fact that you've said that all seven
of these guys are good workers they're
just not six of them don't have a good
attitude about being team players there
is a difference you can be a good worker
but not a good team player and I just
wonder if they are good workers it
implies to me that they have good
character so maybe you come alongside of
them and say this is a way to grow in
your life and and here's why we do this
this the the talk that Dave just gave
that whole we talk I think you're gonna
have to train some of them if they've
got good character and they work hard it
is plausible that they could be a good
team player but you're gonna have to
cast vision and show them specifically
like Dave was laying out I'd rework that
exactly how Dave said it I'd say it that
way because I think good workers Dave
imply good character and some of these
young men haven't been taught
how to to be a team player you get
socialized by the people you hang out
with boom and if you're hanging out with
people say well the little man can't get
ahead
thank God it's Friday it's true oh God
it's Monday if that's who you hang out
with you're gonna sound just like them
in a month
so you need some new friends
really if eor is their spirit animal
they gotta go we gotta move on to
something else oh it's bad it's just
awful I don't know how we're gonna make
it
jeez I'm on this is the Ramsay show